[MUSIC PLAYING]
The idea behind
interactive Robogami
is that we want to make
robots easier to customize
and easier to create for people
who are not necessarily trained
in engineering design.
And so we've basically
designed the system
which allows people to do
this design very intuitively.
There are two main
ideas behind it.
One is easy
fabrication, and one is
being able to virtually
verify that your robot will
work once it's been fabricated.
On the fabrication
side, we've been
using 3D printing and
folding techniques in order
to make the
fabrication very easy.
And on the functionality
side, we've
incorporated
simulations in order
to make sure that the robot can
actually walk and can actually
perform tasks.
3D printing has a
lot of advantages.
You can print very
complex structures.
They're very rigid.
Whereas in 2D fabrication,
it's very fast
and you can create basically
lightweight but still strong
structures.
We took the advantage
of both of them
and we decided to 3D
print 2D patterns.
So this allowed us to get
very rapid fabrication
of stiff structures that
are still lightweight.
So designing a
robot is challenging
because there are many
aspects that must be designed.
You have the 3D shape, the
motion, the electronics,
the control software.
So how do you allow a casual
user of any skill level
to design all of these
aspects at the same time
to create a robot that
will solve the user's task?
Using our system, users
can create a robot body
by simply mixing and matching
parts from an existing catalog.
And in the same way, the user
designs a motion for the robot
by selecting from a
list of suggestions
and modifying the
motion parameters.
And all of the models
designed in the system
can be directly fabricated
and they are guaranteed
to work in the real world.
So what makes interactive
Robogami powerful
is that it helps
users in designing
robots that will perform
tasks well by guiding
users in improving
both the motion
and the geometry of
the robot designs.
For instance, making the
robots faster or more stable
or decreasing the
fabrication costs
to make them more affordable.
What we've put into
the database are
a lot of wheeled robots
and some legged robots.
You could combine
any part you want
in the database
with any other part
into as complex a
structure as you want.
Our system would help you
make that design functional.
What we envision
for the future is
that a user would be able
to go into the system
and basically define the
behavior of this robot in terms
of tasks.
You can very quickly design
a tool that you can print out
and that will help you do
these tasks very cheaply, very
quickly, very easily.
So the dream is
that this tool would
enable robots to
become prevalent
in our everyday lives.
Since the system is geared
towards making design easy,
making fabrication
easy, then it's
basically lowering the barrier
to having everybody design
and create their own robots.
[MUSIC PLAYING]